No,
some people try to draw a line and say,
well,
some animals are this and other animals,
so not,
and there are differences across
species,
but all species,
all individuals within a species deserve
to be treated with respect and
compassion.
As individuals.
I see everything on a continuum.
I see psychological continuity between
humans and the other animals and across
a dolphins and primates,
and that simply reflects the fact that
evolution works by building upon
existing structures and processes.
So that's reflected in the fact that we
all share a common psychology and each
species each.
If you're an individual,
no matter whether you're a dolphin or a
monkey or a person or an Aardvark,
you have that basic psychology that's
just changed a little bit depending upon
what species you are.